In the midterm elections, Democrats, of course, are gunning to retake the House of Representatives. And the 19th congressional district in New York is one of the spots they think they've got a great shot at. Demographically, it's one of the rare districts in the country that is actually a true tossup. It went for Donald Trump by seven points but before that it went for Barack Obama. It's pretty much evenly split between Democrats and Republicans.
在中期选举中，民主党人当然渴望夺回众议院。纽约第19国会选区是他们认为有很大胜算的地方之一。从人口统计学上讲，这是全国为数不多的真正势均力敌的选区之一。唐纳德·特朗普以7个百分点的优势赢得了该选区，但在那之前，巴拉克·奥巴马曾赢得该选区。民主党和共和党在这里的支持率几乎平分秋色。
And to make it even more attractive to Democrats, the Republican on the seat right now-- his name is John Faso. He's the kind of opponent the Democrats dream of getting. He's only been in office for one term. He's a former lobbyist. His clients include payday loan companies and energy companies.
为了让它对民主党人更具吸引力，现任共和党议员名叫约翰·法索（John Faso）。他是民主党人梦寐以求的那种对手。他只担任了一届公职。他是一位前游说者，客户包括发薪日贷款公司和能源公司。
Supporting Faso you've got all the right wing funders the Democrats love to hate-- the Koch brothers, the Mercers, Paul Singer. Add to that, Faso's done a decent job of spending his first term in Congress handing out ammunition to Democrats.
支持法索的都是民主党人深恶痛绝的右翼金主——科赫兄弟、默瑟家族、保罗·辛格。除此之外，法索在国会的第一任期内做得很“出色”，为民主党人提供了不少攻击他的弹药。
One of our producers, Ben Calhoun, has spent months visiting the district covering this race. Ben?
我们的制片人之一本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）已经在该选区花了好几个月的时间报道这场竞选。本？
Yeah. So, the best example of what you're talking about is this video. And I'll say, I was so surprised at how often this video has come up when I've been reporting in the district over the last three months. People just mention this thing all the time. So in this video, Faso's completely surrounded by these protesters who are all opposing the Republican repeal of the Affordable Care Act-- the repeal of Obamacare. And this woman comes up to him.
是的。你能谈到的最好的例子就是这段视频。我想说，在过去三个月里，我在该选区报道时，这段视频被提到的频率之高让我感到非常惊讶。人们一直在提起这件事。在这段视频中，法索被一群抗议者团团围住，他们都反对共和党废除《平价医疗法案》——也就是废除奥巴马医改。然后这个女人向他走来。
I grew up right down the road.
我就在路那头长大。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
The woman's name here is Andrea Mitchell. And she explains to Faso, she's not just like any constituent. She went to school with Faso's kids. Like, Faso's wife was her school nurse. And she tells Faso that she has a brain tumor and Obamacare saved her health insurance. And then she pleads with Faso for him not to support the Republican repeal of Obamacare.
这个女人的名字叫安德里亚·米切尔（Andrea Mitchell）。她向法索解释说，她不仅仅是一位普通选民。她和法索的孩子是同学。法索的妻子曾是她的校医。她告诉法索，她患有脑瘤，是奥巴马医改挽救了她的健康保险。然后她恳求法索不要支持共和党废除奥巴马医改。
I need you, as a human being, to say I promise that we will not take this away from you.
我需要你作为一个人类，向我承诺你们不会夺走它。
I can tell you this--
我可以告诉你这个——
Until--
直到——
I promise. I promise.
我承诺。我承诺。
It's hard to hear in there, but Faso says to Andrea Mitchell, I can tell you that. I promise, I promise, I promise. He promises her three times. And then in the video he hugs her. And he seems kind of moved.
在视频里听得不是很清楚，但法索对安德里亚·米切尔说，我可以告诉你这个。我承诺，我承诺，我承诺。他向她承诺了三次。然后在视频中他拥抱了她。他看起来有点被打动了。
So Faso promises he's not going to support the Republican bill that's going to kill Obamacare. And then we can just cut to Faso on the floor of the House a few months later voting for the bill to kill Obamacare.
所以法索承诺他不会支持共和党废除奥巴马医改的法案。然后我们转眼几个月后，法索就在众议院投票支持了这项废除奥巴马医改的法案。
Mr. Speaker, my colleagues, I urge support for the bill. It is something that is long overdue.
议长先生，各位同仁，我敦促大家支持这项法案。这是早就该做的事。
And then he voted for the bill?
然后他投票支持了这项法案？
Yeah. Faso's spokesperson said later that Andrea Mitchell wouldn't have lost her coverage because of the vote but that's unclear. So that vote, the one to gut Obamacare, it's one of the votes that puts Republicans at greater risk when they're trying to get elected this year. And Democrats are totally coming after him.
是的。法索的发言人后来表示，安德里亚·米切尔并不会因为这次投票而失去保险，但这并不清楚。所以那次投票，即废除奥巴马医改的投票，是共和党人今年竞选时面临更大风险的原因之一。民主党人完全是在紧追他不放。
Greetings from the Resistance in front of John Faso's Kingston office.
向约翰·法索金斯顿办公室前的抵抗运动致意。
OK, where are we now?
好的，我们现在在哪？
This is sound from protests that have been happening outside of Faso's district offices every Friday. They call them Faso Fridays. And this one is from Kingston, New York. And it has a house band, called the Tin Horn Uprising.
这些声音来自每周五在法索地区办公室外举行的抗议活动。他们称之为“法索星期五”。这是在纽约州金斯顿举行的。他们还有一个家庭乐队，叫“锡喇叭起义”（Tin Horn Uprising）。
[MUSIC - "GET UP, STAND UP" BY TIN HORN UPRISING]
[音乐 - “起来，站起来”（Get Up, Stand Up），由锡喇叭起义演奏]
That is not a good version of that song.
那首歌的版本不太好听。
Yeah. It was actually kind of hard to pick which song to play for you.
是的。其实很难决定该给你们播放哪首歌。
[MUSIC - BY TIN HORN UPRISING]
[音乐 - 由锡喇叭起义演奏]
I feel like the band from the Star Wars cantina is trying to overturn this Congressman.
我觉得《星球大战》坎蒂娜酒吧里的乐队正试图推翻这位国会议员。
Yeah, no. Let me do one more. We're going to go Seasonal.
不，不。让我再放一首。我们要来点应景的。
[MUSIC - "SANTA CLAUS IS COMING TO TOWN' BY TIN HORN UPRISING]
[音乐 - “圣诞老人进城了”（Santa Claus is Coming to Town），由锡喇叭起义演奏]
No comment.
无可奉告。
So these kinds of protests have been kind of a genre for democratic activists all around the country. You've got Tuesdays with Toomey, Fridays with Frelinghuysen.
所以，这类抗议活动已经成为了全国各地民主党活动人士的一种常态。你们有“图米星期二”（Tuesdays with Toomey）、“弗里林海森星期五”（Fridays with Frelinghuysen）。
These are just in different districts around the country?
这些只是全国不同选区的活动吗？
Yeah, all over the place. So all of that means, New York 19, it's just like one of the hottest targets for Democrats across the whole country. It's one of the seats that Democrats really believe they can flip, and that they need to flip if they're going to retake the House-- like top 15 easily. That's according to somebody who I talked to at the Democratic Party.
是的，到处都有。所以这一切意味着，纽约第19选区是民主党人在全国范围内最热门的目标之一。这是民主党人真心认为他们可以翻转的席位之一，如果他们想夺回众议院，他们需要翻转这个席位——轻松进入前15名。这是我从民主党内部人士那里听到的。
OK, so the Democrats are dying to take the House and they're full of energy, they're full of enthusiasm. But at the same time, they don't agree how to take the House. And there's this big messy fight over ideas and strategy between different groups in the party. And Ben, you've reported on this before here on our show.
好的，民主党人渴望夺回众议院，他们充满了精力和热情。但与此同时，他们并不认同该如何夺回众议院。党内不同团体之间就理念和策略存在着巨大的混乱斗争。本，你以前在我们的节目中报道过这个。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
And one of the reasons it's so contentious is that each faction thinks that the other faction could totally blow the Democrat's chances to win this fall. And New York 19, this congressional district we've been talking about, this is a district where that kind of fight is going on. And Ben, you've been following one of the candidates in that race.
之所以如此有争议，原因之一是每个派系都认为另一个派系可能会彻底毁掉民主党今年秋天的获胜机会。而我们一直在谈论的纽约第19国会选区，正是这种斗争正在上演的地方。本，你一直在追踪那场竞选中的一位候选人。
Yeah, his name is Jeff Beals.
是的，他叫杰夫·比尔斯（Jeff Beals）。
Hi, how are you doing? Just wanted to say hi. I'm Jeff Beals. Don't be alarmed. I'm running for Congress.
你好，你好吗？只是想打个招呼。我是杰夫·比尔斯。别惊慌。我正在竞选国会议员。
That's Beals knocking on doors right there. And I got interested in him because he's emblematic of this whole political moment. The way he became politically active, some of the things that he believes, but also, maybe most important he was just willing to talk in this super honest way about things that were going on behind the scenes as Democrats are fighting with each other. And he just told me about conversations that you don't normally get to hear about in politics until maybe after an election is over. You know I've been covering people running for Congress for maybe 15 years and I've just never had somebody talk to me this way.
这就是比尔斯在挨家挨户敲门。我对比尔斯感兴趣，是因为他是这一整个政治时刻的缩影。他变得活跃的方式、他所信仰的一些理念，但也许最重要的是，他愿意以一种极其诚实的方式谈论幕后发生的事情，特别是在民主党内部互相争斗的时候。他告诉了我一些在选举结束前通常不会听到的谈话。你知道，我报道人们竞选国会议员已经有15年了，但我从来没有见过像他这样跟我说话的人。
OK, so that is our show today. We're going to watch this big soupy fight that's going on at the Democratic Party play out, through the experience that this one candidate, Jeff Beals, has had. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And Ben Calhoun takes a story from here.
好的，这就是我们今天的节目。我们将通过这位候选人杰夫·比尔斯的经历，来看看民主党内部这场巨大的混乱斗争是如何上演的。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。而本·卡尔霍恩将从这里讲述这个故事。
Jeff Beals remembers the day that he decided to run for Congress. He was a high school teacher. He teaches history and civics and he was killing time between classes.
杰夫·比尔斯记得他决定竞选国会议员的那一天。他当时是一名高中教师。他教历史和公民课，当时正在课间休息。
I'm sitting in-- we have a little room, kind of a break room they'll let us use off the library where you could grab a cup of coffee. And I'm sitting there reading the news. And I see a blog post that people have declared their run for Congress in New York 19. And I say, oh, OK. Who's that? That's good. We got to beat-- got to beat Faso. And then I read about who it is. And one of them is an attorney from the largest lobbying law firm in the United States. Another one of them is a medical devices CEO who, off a link in that very article, is running a factory that's off shored American jobs.
我坐在——我们有一个小房间，算是休息室，他们让我们在图书馆旁边用，你可以在那里喝杯咖啡。我坐在那里看新闻。我看到一篇博客文章说，人们已经宣布在纽约第19选区竞选国会议员。我说，哦，好吧。那是谁？很好。我们必须击败——必须击败法索。然后我读了关于那是谁的内容。其中一个是来自美国最大的游说律师事务所的律师。另一个是医疗设备公司的首席执行官，从那篇文章的一个链接里可以看到，他经营的一家工厂把美国的工作岗位外包出去了。
Beals is like, whoa, hold up. Wait a minute.
比尔斯心想，哇，等一下。慢着。
This isn't matching what I think needs to happen right now.
这和我认为现在需要发生的事情不符。
In 2016, he watched Hillary Clinton deploy the strategy Democrats have used for years. She raised tons of money from big donors and lobbyists and pushed moderate positions designed to offend as few people as possible. Beals and other Democrats, the ones on the Bernie side of things, thought that the party had lost its credibility with Americans. It was too cozy with Wall Street, too corporate, too insider, and out of touch. They saw Clinton as the pinnacle of what had become a losing strategy.
2016年，他目睹了希拉里·克林顿采用了民主党多年来使用的策略。她从大捐赠者和游说者那里筹集了大量资金，并推动了一些旨在尽可能少得罪人的温和立场。比尔斯和其他民主党人，那些站在桑德斯一边的民主党人，认为民主党已经失去了在美国人民心中的信誉。它与华尔街走得太近，过于商业化、过于精英化，并且与现实脱节。他们将克林顿视为这种失败策略的巅峰。
I have total contempt for it because they're-- we just lost the presidency and outraised Donald Trump. So I'm just totally-- I've totally fed up with the concept that money is the answer to how you win an election because it self-evidently didn't win an election. It lost an election.
我对此感到完全的鄙视，因为他们——我们刚刚失去了总统职位，而且筹款额超过了唐纳德·特朗普。所以我完全——我完全受够了金钱是赢得选举的关键这一概念，因为它显然没有赢得选举。它输掉了选举。
After Clinton's defeat, Beals was upset and worried. And like a lot of Democrats, he started signing up for all kinds of stuff-- protest, voter registration stuff. He became a member of his local Democratic Committee. And he noticed how excited Democrats were to stand up to the new President. Beals signed up with a group to host a house party.
克林顿失败后，比尔斯感到不安和担忧。像许多民主党人一样，他开始报名参加各种活动——抗议、选民登记等等。他成为了当地民主党委员会的成员。他注意到民主党人对站出来反对新总统感到多么兴奋。比尔斯加入了一个团队来举办家庭聚会。
Tons of strangers RSVP'd-- over 100 people, too many for his little apartment. He ended up having to hold it in a coffee shop. It shaped his view of what's possible this year and of what the party should be doing. So Beals is in the teacher's lounge, sipping coffee, reading about these candidates.
无数陌生人回复参加——超过100人，对于他那小小的公寓来说太多了。他最后不得不把它安排在一家咖啡店举行。这塑造了他对比尔斯今年所能达到的目标以及民主党应该做些什么的看法。所以，比尔斯坐在教师休息室里，一边喝着咖啡，一边读着那些候选人的报道。
One is a corporate executive whose company does its manufacturing overseas. Another is a lawyer from a big lobbying firm, a lawyer whose job is defending Wall Street guys. And he thought, you've got to be joking. We cannot seriously be doing this again especially in New York 19.
一个是企业高管，他的公司在海外进行制造。另一个是大型游说公司的律师，一个职业是为华尔街辩护的律师。他心想，你们一定是在开玩笑。我们绝不能认真地再次这样做，尤其是在纽约第19选区。
Beals thought that New York 19 was the kind of place that was ripe for a different kind of campaign because Bernie Sanders had won big there-- crushed Clinton 58% to 41%. This is in her home state. Beals thought he understood why. New York 19 is an enormous district, about an hour north of New York City. It's speckled with second homes of well-heeled New Yorkers.
比尔斯认为纽约第19选区是一个适合不同类型竞选的地方，因为伯尼·桑德斯在那里大获全胜——以58%对41%的优势碾压了克林顿。这还是在她自己的家乡州。比尔斯认为他理解其中的原因。纽约第19选区是一个巨大的选区，在纽约市以北约一小时路程。这里点缀着富裕的纽约人的度假屋。
But it's also rural and working class with big swaths of poverty. Beals thought, this place has a populist streak which is partly why Trump took it in the general election, he thought. It's the kind of place where you can win back some of those Trump voters with a kind of surly, stick up for the little guy, drain the swamp sort of pitch, and drive up democratic turnout with loud progressive ideas to get Democrats pumped. Beals thought that's the right plan, especially right now.
但它同时也是一个贫困人口众多的农村和工人阶级地区。比尔斯认为，这个地方有一种民粹主义倾向，这在某种程度上是他认为特朗普在普选中赢得它的原因。他认为，这是一种你可以通过那种愤世嫉俗、为小人物挺身而出、“抽干沼泽”式的竞选主张来赢回部分特朗普选民的地方，并用响亮的进步理念来提高民主党的投票率，让民主党人振奋起来。比尔斯认为这就是正确的计划，特别是在现在这个时候。
It's not all stupid naivety. It's an awareness of the extraordinary moment we're at. If I, in 2016, OK? If in 2016 I had ventured to run for Congress all off of volunteer energy it wouldn't have materialized, period. There's not volunteer energy of sufficient magnitude. 100 people are not going to show up outside the Ulster County Courthouse to see you give some speech about the moral of American history and your life in it.
这并非完全是愚蠢的幼稚。这是对我们所处非凡时刻的一种认知。如果在2016年，好吧？如果在2016年，我冒险仅凭志愿者的热情去竞选国会议员，那是不可能实现的，绝对不可能。没有足够规模的志愿者热情。不会有100人出现在阿尔斯特县法院外，听你发表关于美国历史道德和你个人生活中经历的演讲。
That's a speech he actually gave.
那确实是他发表过的一次演讲。
But all that's possible right now.
但现在这一切都是可能的。
Beals was about to spend the next 12 months betting everything he had on that idea. Like dozens of progressive candidates all over the country, Beals felt certain. Democrats could win with a progressive message, a call to overhaul their own party. He wanted to put that vision head-to-head up against the old strategy he hated so much. He was about to discover just how much the Democratic Party's current philosophy, fundraising, and strategy is stacked against a plan like his.
比尔斯正准备花接下来12个月的时间，把他拥有的一切都押在这个想法上。就像全国各地数十位进步派候选人一样，比尔斯感到很确定。民主党人可以凭借进步派的信息和呼吁改革党内自身的号召获胜。他想把他那种愿景与他所憎恨的旧策略进行正面对抗。他很快就会发现，民主党目前的理念、筹款和策略在多大程度上与他的计划背道而驰。
Come on up here, Jeff Beals.
上来吧，杰夫·比尔斯。
Beals declared his candidacy on June 16th, 2017 on the steps of this old courthouse. In front of him, he had a podium he just bought on the internet and a crowd of what looks like 100 people spilling out into the street, cheering for all the progressive stuff-- free college tuition, break up the big banks, green New Deal, income inequality.
比尔斯于2017年6月16日在老法院的台阶上宣布了他的候选资格。在他面前，他放了一个刚在网上买的讲台，还有一群看起来有100人的人群涌向街道，为所有的进步主义理念欢呼——免费大学学费、拆分大银行、绿色新政、收入不平等。
We're not just protesting anymore. We're not just asking for our congressman's ear. We want his seat! My name is Jeff Beals. I'm running for Congress to win back our voice in this district. And give yourselves a round of applause because we just started! Thank you.
我们不再只是抗议了。我们不再只是请求我们国会议员的关注。我们要他的席位！我叫杰夫·比尔斯。我正在竞选国会议员，以赢回我们在该选区的发言权。为你们自己鼓掌吧，因为我们才刚刚开始！谢谢。
Before Beals taught high school history and civics, he had the kind of biography that'd make you think, that guy could run for Congress. He graduated Harvard, where he studied Arabic and political science. Then he became an analyst at the CIA. After that he was a diplomat at the State Department. He went to Iraq where he worked on the transitional government and the Iraqi constitution.
在比尔斯教高中历史和公民课之前，他有着那种会让你觉得“那家伙可以竞选国会议员”的履历。他毕业于哈佛大学，在那里学习阿拉伯语和政治学。之后他成为中情局的一名分析师。此后，他是国务院的一名外交官。他去了伊拉克，在那里从事过渡政府和伊拉克宪法的工作。
When he was in training at the State Department, his colleagues voted him most likely to write a dissent cable, which is a kind of memo where someone essentially pulls the fire alarm to say something is terribly wrong. He's not shy about taking a contrary position. And by the time Beals left Iraq and the State Department, he was really disillusioned with how it had gone. He wanted to get away from government. Tried grad school and academia, drifted a little, and then started substitute teaching high school.
当他在国务院接受培训时，他的同事们投票选他为“最有可能写异议电报”的人，这是一种备忘录，本质上是某人拉响火警，说有些事情大错特错。他不怕采取相反的立场。而当比尔斯离开伊拉克和国务院时，他对比事情的发展真的感到幻灭。他想离开政府。尝试了研究生院和学术界，漂泊了一段时间，然后开始在高中当替补教师。
He found that he loved it. He took a job at a private school, the job he has now. One thing about running for Congress-- you don't actually have to ask anyone for permission. You just start saying you're running for Congress and people are like, oh, that person is running for Congress. And then something like this happens.
他发现他喜欢上了这份工作。他在一所私立学校找了一份工作，也就是他现在的工作。竞选国会议员的一点是——你实际上不需要征求任何人的允许。你只需要开始说你在竞选国会议员，人们就会说，哦，那个人在竞选国会议员。然后就会发生这样的事情。
Very quickly I got a phone call from the Democratic Congressional Campaign Committee, can we talk? And I'm like, so who is this? OK.
很快，我接到了民主党国会竞选委员会的电话，我们可以谈谈吗？我当时心想，这是谁？好吧。
For people outside Washington, the Democratic Party is the Democratic Party, right? But it's made up of smaller subgroups. The Democratic Congressional Campaign Committee is the political arm of Democrats in the House of Representatives. In Washington it goes by the acronym DCCC , or just The D Trip. They help Democrats win seats in Congress by recruiting candidates, training people, helping with strategy and fundraising.
对于华盛顿以外的人来说，民主党就是民主党，对吧？但它由更小的子群体组成。民主党国会竞选委员会（DCCC）是民主党在众议院的政治分支。在华盛顿，它通常被称为DCCC，或者简称为“D Trip”。他们通过招募候选人、培训人员、帮助制定策略和筹款来帮助民主党人在国会获胜。
And last spring, when the DCCC reached out to Jeff Beals he thought, maybe it was to talk about how they might help him. So they planned a phone call, 4:00 PM, after Beals finishes teaching. So the day arrives, Jeff's ready. But before the clock hits 4:00 PM--
去年春天，当DCCC联系杰夫·比尔斯时，他想，也许他们是想谈谈他们如何能帮助他。所以他们计划在下午4点，也就是比尔斯放学后进行一次通话。日子到了，杰夫准备好了。但在时钟敲响下午4点之前——
My phone rings at about 3:50?
我的电话大约在3点50分响了？
It's a woman he knows. She's like, answer your next call. So they hang up, and then that call comes in.
那是一个他认识的女人。她说，接你的下一个电话。所以他们挂断了，然后那个电话进来了。
And it's a political guy I've never met on the phone. And he says, you're about to have a conversation with the DCCC at 4:00. I think you're a strong candidate. But you have to be ready for this conversation. They're going to ask you two questions.
电话那头是一个我从未见过的政治人物。他说，你将在4点与DCCC进行谈话。我认为你是一个强有力的候选人。但你必须为这次谈话做好准备。他们会问你两个问题。
And I said, what? He said, they're going to ask you two questions. Question number one is, how much money can you raise in the first quarter? And I said, oh, OK, that's the first question? He said, yes.
我说，什么？他说，他们会问你两个问题。第一个问题是，你在第一季度能筹集到多少钱？我说，哦，好的，这是第一个问题？他说，是的。
So I go, what's the answer? He goes, $300,000. And I said, so what's question number two? He goes, question number two is, how much do you think you need to raise overall to win this race? What's the answer to that? He said, $2 million.
所以我说，答案是什么？他说，30万美元。我说，那么第二个问题是什么？他说，第二个问题是，你认为你需要筹集多少资金才能赢得这场竞选？答案是什么？他说，200万美元。
The guy tells Beals, give those answers, let's talk later.
那人告诉比尔斯，给出这些答案，我们以后再谈。
4:00, bing! Like, OK, I've got to get off the phone. I've got to take that 4:00 phone call. I hopped in my car.
4点，叮！就像是，好的，我必须挂断电话。我必须接那个4点的电话。我跳进我的车里。
Jeff dials up the guy from The D Trip.
杰夫拨通了那个“D Trip”家伙的电话。
And he says, hi, Jeff. I have a couple questions for you. How much money do you think you can raise in the first quarter? And I said, $300,000? He goes, sounds good. How much do you think you will need to raise in order to win this race? And I'm like, two-- two million? Is that-- good answer. Well, sounds like things are off to a good start there. Keep in touch. We'll be in touch. Conversation basically ends.
他说，嗨，杰夫。我有几个问题要问你。你认为你在第一季度能筹集多少钱？我说，30万美元？他说，听起来不错。你认为你需要筹集多少资金才能赢得这场竞选？我说，两——200万？那是——好的答案。嗯，听起来事情开局不错。保持联系。我们会保持联系。谈话基本上结束了。
A DCCC spokesperson told me there was more to this conversation but Beals maintains it was very, very focused on money. When he hung up, he was surprised by what wasn't in the conversation. What kind of organization have you set up? What activists and groups are connected to? Or even more just, what do you stand for? But so, Beals gets back on the phone with the democratic insider advisor guy. That guy did want to talk about what Jeff stood for.
一位DCCC发言人告诉我，这次谈话的内容远不止这些，但比尔斯坚称重点非常、非常集中在金钱上。当他挂断电话时，他对谈话中没有提到的内容感到惊讶。你建立了什么样的组织？你与哪些活动家和团体有联系？甚至更简单的，你的立场是什么？但是，比尔斯又和那位民主党内部顾问通了电话。那个人确实想谈谈杰夫的立场。
And said, you know, so what is your platform? You're probably not going to want to go single payer. It's not a winner. OK, not a winning issue. There's a lot of problems there.
他说，你知道，那么你的纲领是什么？你可能不想推行单一支付者医疗制度。那不是赢家。好吧，不是一个制胜的议题。那里有很多问题。
Single payer, government run nationalized health care-- everyone gets health insurance from the government. Back when the Republicans were trying to repeal Obamacare, Bernie Sanders launched a big push for this under the label Medicare For All. He chose that name because polls show that people love Medicare. And when he did this, Sanders sort of put a dividing line in the Democratic Party.
单一支付者，政府运作的国有化医疗保健——每个人都从政府那里获得健康保险。早在共和党人试图废除奥巴马医改时，伯尼·桑德斯就以“全民医保”（Medicare For All）的名义发起了对此的大力推动。他选择了这个名字，因为民调显示人们喜欢医疗保险（Medicare）。当他这样做时，桑德斯在民主党内部划出了一条分界线。
On one side, you had the moderate and establishment wing of the party that was all, single payer health care? Hold your horses there, Che Guevara. Do you remember the epic political beating we took over Obamacare for crying out loud?
在一边，你有民主党的温和派和建制派，他们说，单一支付者医疗保健？别急着下结论，切·格瓦拉。还记得我们因为奥巴马医改而遭受的巨大的政治打击吗？
And then on the Sanders side of the line, you had the progressive wing of the party who were all, radical. Most Americans support it. Right now it's like 60%-- plus, it's exciting. You want to make a comeback, how about we run on something people are excited about, you timid bastards. Jeff's on that side of the line.
而在桑德斯的界线那一边，有党内的进步派，他们说，太激进了。大多数美国人支持它。现在大约有60%的人支持——此外，这很令人兴奋。你想东山再起吗，为什么我们不利用人们感到兴奋的事情来竞选呢，你们这些胆小的混蛋。杰夫站在那一边。
And I said, but I do support single payer. That's one of the crucial, crucial elements of my candidacy. I don't have health insurance through my job. It is one of the most awful parts of my life. Not to mention how much more awful it is for people that are worse off than me in our district.
我说，但我确实支持单一支付者。这是我竞选最关键、最关键的要素之一。我没有通过工作获得健康保险。这是我生活中最糟糕的部分之一。更不用说对于那些在我们选区里生活得比我更差的人来说，情况有多糟糕了。
So you said that in that conversation?
所以你在那次谈话中说了这些？
Yeah, I said absolutely I'm for single payer. That's the whole campaign. I mean, look there's a lot of issues. But if there is one thing we could do right now to make life better in America for the vast majority of Americans, it would be passing Medicare for All now and enacting it.
是的，我说我绝对支持单一支付者。这是整个竞选的核心。我的意思是，看，有很多议题。但如果现在有一件事我们可以做，能让绝大多数美国人的生活变得更好，那就是立即通过并实施“全民医保”。
At some point, the guy on the phone turned to fundraising, how to hit the DCCC fundraising numbers. He said, I know it sounds like a lot but you can do it. Make a list of everyone you know and how much money you can get from each of them. I should say, this is conventional advice for new candidates. People call it rolodexing.
在某个时候，电话那头的人转到了筹款上，讨论如何达到DCCC的筹款目标。他说，我知道这听起来很多，但你可以做到的。列出你认识的每个人，以及你能从他们每个人那里筹集多少钱。我应该说，这对新候选人来说是传统的建议。人们称之为“滚号簿”（rolodexing）。
It's often done by political operatives to test whether candidates can raise the kind of money that politics often requires these days. Consider that in 2016, the average winning congressional campaign had to raise $1.5 million. Party operatives like to figure out if people can do that, and this is a shortcut. But it's a shortcut that ignores other things that are often tougher to measure-- grassroots involvement, activism. Even more, it's obviously a screening process that discriminates heavily in favor of rich candidates with rich friends and rich colleagues and against, well, most Americans.
这通常由政治经纪人完成，以测试候选人是否能筹集到这些天政治通常需要的资金。考虑到2016年，平均胜选的国会竞选需要筹集150万美元。党内经纪人喜欢搞清楚人们是否能做到这一点，这是一种捷径。但它忽略了其他往往更难衡量的因素——草根参与、激进主义。更重要的是，这显然是一个极大地歧视富裕候选人及其富有的朋友和同事，而反对，嗯，大多数美国人的筛选过程。
How did you feel when you got off of that second phone call?
当你接完第二个电话时，你的感觉如何？
I think that, I just felt like I was talking to people who didn't have any idea what I was doing or what I cared about. And it was disconcerting. And it made me sad, momentarily. But I was surrounded in real life by so many people who were excited about the things that I was excited about and doing it for the reason that I was doing it that I just decided those people were irrelevant. And if they weren't irrelevant then I'd have to make them irrelevant.
我想，我只是觉得我是在和那些根本不知道我在做什么或我不关心什么的人说话。这让人不安。它让我难过了一会儿。但我现实生活中被这么多对我也同样兴奋的事情感到兴奋的人所包围，他们做这件事的原因也是我做这件事的原因，所以我决定那些人根本无关紧要。如果他们不是无关紧要的，那我也得让他们变得无关紧要。
The DCCC usually is less relevant during a primary. In the general election, though, if they think you're a winner they'll tell people to give you money. They'll supply polling data, introduce you to consultants. They'll buy TV commercials for you.
DCCC在初选期间通常影响力较小。但在普选中，如果他们认为你是赢家，他们会告诉人们给你捐钱。他们会提供民调数据，把你介绍给顾问。他们会为你购买电视广告。
So Beals got to work. With or without the DCCC, he knew he was going to need money. Hopefully, he thought, not as much money as the DCCC had told him on that call. But he was sure he was going to need some. So he set out to raise it.
所以比尔斯开始工作了。无论有没有DCCC，他都知道他需要钱。他希望，不需要DCCC在电话里告诉他的那么多钱。但他肯定他需要一些。所以他开始筹集资金。
And when Beals started, he was optimistic. Sure, he knew, progressive politics aren't every Democrats' bag. But he thought surely there's some deep pocketed progressive types out there-- you know, Warren Buffett types who are all, I'm crazy rich! Tax me more. It's going to be good for America. People started trying to hook Beals up.
当比尔斯开始时，他很乐观。当然，他知道，进步派政治并不是每个民主党人的那杯茶。但他想，肯定有一些腰缠万贯的进步派人士——你知道，像沃伦·巴菲特那样的人，他们会说，我富得发疯！多向我征税。这对美国有好处。人们开始试图帮助比尔斯。
A friend of mine, who was with the Clinton campaign, had a birthday party.
我的一个朋友，曾效力于克林顿竞选团队，举办了一个生日派对。
This was a buddy from the State Department, politically connected, and he wanted to help Beals. He was like, come to my birthday. There's going to be influential people there. You can give a speech and you can raise some money. It's going to be great.
这是一个来自国务院的好哥们，有政治背景，他想帮助比尔斯。他说，来参加我的生日聚会。那里会有有影响力的人。你可以发表讲话，筹集一些资金。那会很棒的。
So I come. This is a swank party-- private room in a nice restaurant where the meal is already paid for and you just choose your entree.
所以我来了。这是一个时髦的派对——在一个不错的餐厅里的私人房间，餐点已经付过了，你只需要选择主菜。
It's a couple of dozen people at this long wooden table. And at one point, the friend introduces Beals. And Beals does the stump speech, just lets it rip. He's feeling it.
长木桌边坐着几十个人。在某个时刻，朋友介绍了比尔斯。比尔斯发表了竞选演讲，畅所欲言。他感觉很好。
Why am I running? I'm running because we've lost control over the economy, income inequality has reached a terrible point where it threatens the basis of our democracy. We failed to take action sufficient to after the 2008 financial crisis and it's only gotten worse. We need Medicare for All now.
我为什么参选？我参选是因为我们已经失去了对经济的控制，收入不平等已经达到了一种可怕的地步，威胁到了我们民主的基础。我们在2008年金融危机后没有采取足够的行动，而情况只会变得更糟。我们现在需要全民医保。
It's a medley of progressive politics in the backroom of a fancy New York restaurant. And you know, he's giving a political speech at a birthday party, which feels weird.
这是在高档纽约餐厅后室里的一场进步派政治集会。而且你知道，他在生日派对上发表政治演说，这感觉很奇怪。
Hard to read a room in a dinner party in a nice restaurant. Like, it's not the break into applause kind of crowd. So when they're silent, you're not necessarily thinking I'm flopping.
在高档餐厅的晚餐派对上很难解读场面。这不像是一个会让你爆发热烈掌声的人群。所以当他们沉默时，你并不一定认为自己搞砸了。
But Jeff wraps it up. Dessert comes, and then his friend flags him down.
但杰夫结束了演讲。甜点送上来了，然后他的朋友向他招手。
And my friend says to me, he goes, what the heck are you doing, man? You gotta tone that down. Do you understand who's in this room? You just alienated everybody here. He goes, that guy is the head of-- and he had some bizarre name, Xanthum Atlas Capitol-- you know, something Capitol. You know, he's like, that's head of it! You know, and he's pointing at this guy and that guy. He's like, this is not going to work. You should have talked about LGBT. That's what he told me.
我的朋友对我说了什么，他说，你到底在做什么，伙计？你需要降低调门。你知道这房间里都是些什么人吗？你刚刚疏远了这里的所有人。他说，那个人是——的负责人，他说了个奇怪的名字，Xanthum Atlas Capitol——你知道，像什么Capitol。你知道，他说，那是它的负责人！你知道，他指着那个人和那个人。他说，这行不通。你应该谈论LGBT。那是他告诉我的。
Did it surprise you when he came up to you and said that?
当他走过来对你说这些话时，你感到惊讶吗？
Yes. I mean, it did. I love him for it. Only your friends will be that straight to you, you know?
是的。我是说，确实。我爱他这一点。只有你的朋友才会对你这么直白，你知道吗？
But Jeff was also kind of shaken up. He respected his friend, respected his friend's political savvy. So Beals called another buddy from the State Department, somebody who knew them both.
但杰夫也感到有点动摇。他尊重他的朋友，尊重他朋友的政治头脑。所以比尔斯给国务院的另一个哥们打了电话，那个既认识他们又认识自己的人。
It did cause me confusion. What am I supposed to be doing here? Because he was really upset. He thought, you really blew a chance. You have no idea how much money was in that room.
这确实引起了我的困惑。我到底应该在这里做什么？因为他真的很沮丧。他认为，你真的错失了一个机会。你不知道那间屋子里有多少钱。
There was a lot of money in that room and you left it on the table. And I called a friend of mine who knows a lot about politics and is on this campaign. And I said to him, this is what our buddy said, that I should have talked LGBT or I shouldn't have addressed those things. And he said, that way lieth the Goldman Sachs speech, Jeff. That way leith the Goldman Sachs speech. Don't. Don't.
那间屋子里有很多钱，而你却把它留在桌子上没拿。我给一个非常了解政治并且参与了这次竞选的朋友打了电话。我对他说，这就是我们要好的哥们说的，我不应该谈论这些事情。他说，那是高盛演讲的方向，杰夫。那是高盛演讲的方向。别那样做。别。
This was a reference to these private events Hillary Clinton got paid to do with Goldman Sachs, saying one thing to them and something different to the public-- catering to rich people, which was one of the very things Beals was running against. So he steeled himself and he continued calling up major democratic donors to find the progressive ones. He says, often these conversations started out friendly enough. People liked Beals' resume, his background qualifications.
这指的是希拉里·克林顿收钱去高盛参加的那些私人活动，对他们说一套，对公众说一套——迎合有钱人，这正是比尔斯竞选所反对的事情。所以他坚定立场，继续给民主党的主要捐赠者打电话，寻找进步派的捐赠者。他说，这些谈话通常开始时还算友好。人们喜欢比尔斯的简历、他的背景资历。
But often things would take a turn. One major democratic donor, a former Goldman Sachs guy actually, he told Beals Medicare for All is a handout. And it's a political loser. Lots of big donors saw it as this lefty thing that could sandbag the party in general elections. They remember the backlash to Obamacare. Another guy, an investment banker type, he says, sure. I'll contribute.
但往往事情会出现转折。一位主要的民主党捐赠者，实际上是一位前高盛的人，他告诉比尔斯，“全民医保”是施舍。而且在政治上是个输家。许多大捐赠者认为这是一个可能在普选中拖累党的左翼的东西。他们记得奥巴马医改引发的反弹。另一个人，投资银行家类型，他说，当然。我会捐款。
I'll contribute to your campaign. But you have to change your website because it says "rigged economy." And you need to change, "rigged economy" on your website. I don't like that. And it's just a distortion. And I said, well, I can't change that.
我会为你的竞选捐款。但你必须改变你的网站，因为它上面写着“被操纵的经济”（rigged economy）。你需要改变网站上的“被操纵的经济”。我不喜欢那个。这简直是一种扭曲。我说，好吧，我不能改变那个。
He couldn't change that because that would mean giving up the main argument he thinks Democrats should be making right now.
他无法改变这一点，因为那意味着放弃他认为民主党现在应该做出的主要论点。
I think that a lot of democratic politics has been about trying to find the least offensive cause to the donor class to rally people around while stepping on the fewest toes. And there are worthy causes you can rally people around. Guns-- you can rally people around that. And you could maybe get to 51-49 and win.
我认为民主党的许多政治工作一直在于寻找最不冒犯捐赠者阶级的目标来团结民众，同时尽可能少地触动利益。有一些值得团结民众的目标。枪支——你可以围绕那个团结民众。你也许能达到51-49的比例并获胜。
Abortion rights, he says, same thing.
堕胎权，他说，也是一样。
You could also there, too, get to 51-49 or better, and win. But I do believe that there is a way bigger axis out there that people with a lot of money don't want us organizing on, and it's the economic axis. That's in axis where you got 1% on one side, and you've got more than 90% on the other side. And you really change politics in America because you're built on the axis against income inequality in a rigged economy. Then you build a very big movement.
你也可以在那里，同样地，达到51-49或更好的比例，并获胜。但我确实相信，外面有一个更大的轴心，有钱人不想让我们围绕它进行组织，那就是经济轴心。那是一个1%的人站在一边，而90%以上的人站在另一边的轴心。如果你真的改变美国的政治，因为你是建立在反对收入不平等和操纵经济的轴心上。那么你就可以建立一个非常大的运动。
The more major democratic donors Beals called, the more amazed he became and how explicit the conversations got, how direct they were in telling him to change what he was saying and campaigning on. Of course, like anybody, Beals figured politics was like this. But it was different to see it in real life, to be in the conversations, to be the person getting his arm twisted. He came to the conclusion that most of the Democratic Party's major donors are against progressive ideas. Research published by the Washington Post backs this up-- major donors do skew moderate.
比尔斯给民主党主要捐赠者打的电话越多，他就越惊讶，谈话内容变得越直白，他们直接告诉他要改变他的谈话内容和竞选纲领。当然，和任何人一样，比尔斯认为政治就是这样。但在现实生活中看到它，参与谈话，成为那个被人拧胳膊的人，感觉是不同的。他得出的结论是，民主党大多数主要捐赠者都反对进步主义理念。《华盛顿邮报》发表的研究支持了这一点——主要捐赠者确实偏向温和派。
Beals felt confident that there were people out there who agreed with him. He just had to connect with them. His plan was to run out and shout this progressive battle cry and hope than an army filled in behind him. And for Beals, the battle cry was Medicare for All.
比尔斯感到很有信心，肯定有人同意他的观点。他只需要与他们联系起来。他的计划是跑出去，大喊这个进步派的战斗口号，希望一支军队在他身后集结。对比尔斯来说，战斗口号就是“全民医保”。
This was June of last year, exactly when Bernie Sanders was stumping for Medicare for All, pressuring Democrats into picking a side. Everyone had to declare which team they were on or they had to dodge. It became the national border between progressives and establishment Democrats. It was exactly the thing Beals would talk about to try to find voters.
那是去年的六月，正是伯尼·桑德斯为“全民医保”奔走，向民主党人施压要求选边站的时候。每个人都必须声明他们站在哪一队，否则就必须回避。这成为了进步派和建制派民主党人之间的国家边界。这正是比尔斯为了寻找选民而要谈论的事情。
Good evening everyone.
大家晚上好。
One of the races first candidate forums was on August 23rd, 2017 at an old church. Around 6:00 PM, Beals walked in the front with about half a dozen other candidates past pews of people fanning themselves. He walked in with a plan that night.
竞选论坛之一是在2017年8月23日在一个老教堂举行的。大约晚上6点，比尔斯带着大约六名其他候选人从前门走了进去，经过了人们扇着扇子的长椅。那天晚上他带着一个计划进去了。
I wanted to be extremely specific.
我想非常具体。
Beals plan, as he sat down on his stool up front, was to declare his support for what Sanders was doing as forcefully as he possibly could. Like, he didn't want to just say Medicare for All. He was like, I don't want to leave any room for doubt. I want to pledge support for the Medicare for All bill that's sitting in the house right now, House Bill 676. So health care comes up.
比尔斯计划，当他在前面的凳子上坐下时，是尽可能有力地宣布他支持桑德斯正在做的事情。就像，他不想给怀疑留下任何空间。他想承诺支持目前在众议院的“全民医保”法案，即众议院第676号法案。所以医疗保健话题出现了。
And I said, we have a health crisis in the district.
我说，我们在选区内有医疗危机。
We have a health care crisis in this country.
我们在全国面临医疗保健危机。
The solution of the crisis Medicare for All, and I support House Resolution 676. And I hear this scream in the audience.
解决这个危机的方法是“全民医保”，我支持众议院第676号决议。我听到了观众席里的尖叫声。
You can actually hear this on the recording of the forum.
你实际上可以在论坛的录音中听到这个。
When I get to Congress, it's called House Resolution 676--
当我进入国会时，它被称为众议院第676号决议——
Woo!
呜！
Medicare for All. And a vote for--
全民医保。以及投票支持——
I have been going to concerts for a very long time. So I'm a very skilled woo-er. So I wooed as loud as I possibly can.
我参加演唱会已经有很长一段时间了。所以我是一个非常熟练的“呜”者。所以我尽可能大声地“呜”了出来。
You've got a veteran woo?
你有一个资深的“呜”者？
Yes. Well practiced.
是的。练习有素。
This is Anique D'Angelo. She's a community organizer. She'd gone to the forum that day with her best friend. Both were Sanders supporters and they were both looking at candidates in New York 19. And they weren't liking what they saw.
这位是阿尼克·德安吉洛（Anique D'Angelo）。她是一位社区组织者。那天她和她最好的朋友一起去了论坛。两人都是桑德斯的拥护者，他们都在观察纽约第19选区的候选人。他们不喜欢他们所看到的。
We were like, oh, you know, maybe we would get behind him if we had to.
我们当时想，哦，你知道，也许如果必须的话，我们会支持他。
You mean, because you were hearing the things that they were proposing and you were like, these don't sound like what? Like what?
你是说，因为你听到了他们提出的建议，而你当时想，这些听起来不像是……什么？像是为了什么？
So we had decided after the last election, after the last primary, that this is the moment that things are going to happen and we need someone who is for universalist programs, supports Medicare for All, and like--
所以我们在上次选举后，在上次初选后决定，这是事情要发生的时刻，我们需要一个支持普遍主义计划、支持“全民医保”的人，并且像是——
You were like, we need to get a real progressive in this race.
你们当时想，我们需要在这次竞选中找一个真正的进步派。
Yeah. Before Bernie I had always thought a moderate is as good as we're going to get.
是的。在伯尼之前，我一直认为温和派就是我们能得到的最好的结果。
This is why Anique yelled, because when Beals said what he said she felt like she had found her candidate. She felt like she wanted a firm commitment on single payer, Medicare for All. And she was hearing Democrats talk about fixing the Affordable Care Act and working towards universal coverage. And if Medicare for All and universal coverage sound like the same thing, here's the difference.
这就是阿尼克尖叫的原因，因为当比尔斯说出他所说的话时，她觉得她找到了她的候选人。她觉得她想要一个对单一支付者、“全民医保”的坚定承诺。而她听到民主党人在谈论修复《平价医疗法案》和致力于普遍覆盖。如果“全民医保”和普遍覆盖听起来像是同一回事，这就是区别。
Medicare for All is national health care. The government takes over the system, gives everyone insurance. Universal coverage is more general. I'd like to get everyone covered somehow. Maybe some people will keep their current insurance. Maybe some people will pay to get Medicare.
“全民医保”是国家医疗保健。政府接管系统，给每个人提供保险。普遍覆盖更笼统。我希望能通过某种方式覆盖所有人。也许有些人会保留他们目前的保险。也许有些人会付费获得医疗保险。
Maybe we leave the system mostly how it is. Maybe we change all of this gradually. Anique isn't looking for this kind of incrementalism. She thinks that's what Democrats always say and then they wuss out. She's fed up.
也许我们基本保留现有的系统。也许我们循序渐进地改变这一切。阿尼克不是在寻找这种渐进主义。她认为这就是民主党人总是说的话，然后他们就退缩了。她受够了。
You know, I am a professional person in my early 30s and can't use my health insurance because I have a $4,000 deductible, right? I mean, I think if you start from a place of, we have to be incremental, you never get to the end goal because there's corporate interests that get in the way, right? If we said, we're doing this, we'll figure it out. How did we get social security, right? We [BLEEP] did it. I don't know if I'm allowed to curse, but--
你知道，我是一个30出头的专业人士，却不能使用我的医疗保险，因为我有4000美元的免赔额，对吧？我的意思是，我认为如果你从我们必须循序渐进这一立场出发，你永远无法达到最终目标，因为有企业利益会挡路，对吧？如果我们说，我们要这么做，我们会想办法的。我们是怎么得到社会保障的，对吧？我们他妈的（[哔]）做到了。我不知道我是否被允许骂人，但——
From that day forward, August 23rd, 2017, Anique D'Angelo was a Beals supporter. She phone banked in the evening, drove to events all across the district. Soon supporters like Anique were fanning out for Beals. The campaign was crystallizing around a plan. Sanders had gotten 35,000 votes in the primary, which Beals saw as 35,000 Aniques scattered all across the district.
从那天起，2017年8月23日，阿尼克·德安吉洛成了比尔斯的支持者。她晚上打电话拉票，开车到选区各处参加活动。很快，像阿尼克这样的支持者就开始为比尔斯奔走。竞选活动围绕一个计划变得清晰起来。桑德斯在初选中获得了3.5万张选票，比尔斯将其视为分散在选区各处的3.5万个“阿尼克”。
So Beals' campaign looked at the map of where those votes had come from, the precincts where Sanders support was the densest. They targeted their efforts there. If they could just get a third of those people, 12,000 votes, they figured they'd have a serious shot because, not to overwhelm you with numbers here, only 19,000 people voted in the last democratic primary. So 12,000-- that could win this one.
所以比尔斯的竞选团队查看了这些选票来源的地图，桑德斯支持率最密集的选区。他们将目标对准了那里。如果他们能得到这些人中的三分之一，即1.2万张选票，他们认为他们就有很大的胜算，因为，不是为了用数字压垮你，上次民主党初选只有1.9万人投票。所以1.2万——那就能赢得这次初选。
Before long came the first real test for Beale's theory that he could run a campaign that didn't rely on big donors and money, that would be fueled by a flood of volunteers and enthusiasm for brash progressive stuff. The test was something that seems kind of basic, getting his name on the ballot. Like I said, it's easy to say you're running for Congress. It's actually hard to get your name on the ballot.
没过多久，比尔斯关于他可以开展一场不依赖大捐赠者和金钱的竞选活动的理论迎来了第一次真正的考验，这场竞选活动将由涌入的志愿者和对大胆的进步主义理念的热情所推动。考验是一件看起来有点基本的事情，把他的名字写在选票上。正如我所说，说你在竞选国会议员很容易。实际上要把你的名字写在选票上很难。
I was told that it would cost $200,000 to get yourself on the ballot.
我被告知要把你的名字写在选票上需要花费20万美元。
How much were you told it would cost?
你被告知要花多少钱？
I was told $200,000. That was an interesting moment, because that would be an obstacle because I don't got that money, period.
我被告知20万美元。那是一个有趣的时刻，因为那将是一个障碍，因为我没有那笔钱，绝对没有。
Here's why it costs so much money. Beale's was told, you're going to need a lawyer on retainer. And you're going to need an army of paid canvassers. And you're going to need those things because getting signatures is harder than it sounds. To get on the ballot in New York 19 requires 1,250 signatures but there are rules. Only registered Democrats can sign. The signature has to be witnessed by another registered Democrat. And people can only sign for one candidate. So if another campaign got there first, you're out of luck. You mess up any of that, the signature can get tossed out. So 1,250-- you can't just get 1,250.
这就是花费这么多钱的原因。比尔斯被告知，你将需要聘请一名律师。你需要一支付费的拉票大军。你将需要这些东西，因为收集签名比听起来要难。在纽约第19选区获得选票需要1250个签名，但有规则。只有注册的民主党人才能签名。签名必须由另一位注册的民主党人见证。而且人们只能为一个候选人签名。所以如果另一个竞选团队先到了，你就没戏了。这些规则你搞砸任何一项，签名都可能被作废。所以1250——你不能只获得1250个。
So all they got to do is find three people who put their middle initial wrong and you're done.
所以他们只需要找到三个人，把他们的中间名首字母写错了，你就完了。
Generally, the thing you do is collect way more than the requirement to send a message to other campaigns not to mess with you. And you hire that lawyer to defend your signatures. All of this for a traditional campaign needs a boatload of money. Beals' staff knew this was a moment to prove themselves.
通常，你所做的是收集远超要求的数量，向其他竞选团队传递一个不要招惹你的信息。而且你雇佣那个律师来捍卫你的签名。对于一个传统竞选活动来说，所有这些都需要大量的资金。比尔斯的员工知道这是证明他们自己的时刻。
We're not going to be on the ballot unless volunteers are willing to carry the campaign forward. And we put out the call and people gathered hundreds of signatures for the campaign. And we wound up with over 3,200 signatures all off this volunteer spirit. And they just did it on their own.
除非志愿者愿意推动竞选活动向前发展，否则我们的名字不会出现在选票上。我们发出了号召，人们为竞选活动收集了数百个签名。我们最终以这种志愿者精神获得了超过3200个签名。他们只是自己做到的。
For Beals, this was vindication, proof that the thing he thought was possible actually might be possible. Proof that the conventional wisdom might be wrong. A campaign like his, it could work.
对比尔斯来说，这是辩护，证明他认为可能的事情实际上可能是可能的。证明传统智慧可能是错的。像他这样的竞选活动，是行得通的。
I mean, I didn't even know all the people that were doing it. And you realize that a campaign is not a thing you run. It's a thing you unleash. And it either is picked up and carried forward by people or it isn't. And that started to happen. And that's-- you know, calling it inspiring is an understatement. That was incredible. And frankly, my whole candidacy has been a gamble on the existence of that. If it's there, then there's a campaign. And if there isn't, then there's no campaign.
我的意思是，我甚至不知道所有做这件事的人。你意识到竞选活动不是你运行的东西。它是你释放的东西。它要么被人们拾起并推动向前，要么就不会。而这开始发生了。你知道，称之为鼓舞人心是轻描淡写的。那是不可思议的。坦率地说，我的整个候选资格都是在赌这种存在的可能性。如果它在那里，那么就有竞选。如果它不在那里，那么就没有竞选。
Ben Calhoun. Coming up, Democrats who are not Jeff Beals. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
本·卡尔霍恩。接下来，不是杰夫·比尔斯的民主党人。节目继续，由芝加哥公共广播电台播出。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, It's My Party and I'll Try If I Want To, about a candidate who's running for Congress for the very first time and what his race tells us about what is happening inside the Democratic Party this year. The candidate we're following, Jeff Beals, is a Bernie Sanders style progressive. And around the country this past year, the climate between the party apparatus and progressives has been pretty toxic at times because of a handful of incidents that progressives have taken as signs of the party's hostility.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《这是我的党，如果我想，我会尝试》（It's My Party and I'll Try If I Want To），关于一位第一次竞选国会议员的候选人，以及他的竞选说明了今年民主党内部正在发生什么。我们追踪的候选人，杰夫·比尔斯，是一位伯尼·桑德斯式的进步派。过去一年在全国范围内，党内机构和进步派之间的气氛有时相当恶劣，因为发生了一些被进步派视为党内敌意信号的小插曲。
The most notorious one was in Texas. The DCCC released opposition research on a progressive candidate named Laura Moser for her primary. Progressives kind of freaked out. There've been a few other blow ups in Pennsylvania, Nebraska, New York, Minnesota, Colorado. Party officials say that they have nothing against progressive congressional candidates or their ideas. In Jeff Beals' race, in New York's 19th congressional district, election day is this coming Tuesday and there's a whole array of candidates. Ben Calhoun picks up our story from here.
最臭名昭著的事件发生在德克萨斯州。DCCC发布了关于一位名叫劳拉·莫泽（Laura Moser）的进步派候选人的反对研究。进步派有点抓狂了。在宾夕法尼亚州、内布拉斯加州、纽约州、明尼苏达州、科罗拉多州还有几次爆发。党内官员说，他们对比进步派国会议员候选人或他们的理念没有任何反感。在杰夫·比尔斯的竞选中，在纽约第19国会选区，选举日是下周二，而且候选人阵容庞大。本·卡尔霍恩从这里继续讲述我们的故事。
By early 2018, seven Democrats had officially declared in the race for New York 19. Seven, I know-- so many. I've gone out with about half of them knocking doors. The most common thing that voters do is they make a joke, some form of holy crap there's a lot of you people!
到2018年初，七名民主党人正式宣布参加纽约第19选区的竞选。七个，我知道——太多了。我已经和他们中的大约一半人一起去敲门了。选民们做的最常见的事情是开个玩笑，某种形式的“天哪，你们这些人真多！”
So let's just spin through the cast. There's an economist and triathlete who jumped in late. As the only woman in the race, got the backing of Emily's List. She's making a fairly bald play for women voters.
所以让我们快速浏览一下演员阵容。有一位经济学家兼铁人三项运动员，很晚才加入。作为竞选中唯一的女性，得到了Emily's List的支持。她正在进行一场相当直白的女性选民争夺战。
I'm not going to let those boys beat me.
我绝不会让那些男孩打败我。
There's a community activist who's also a personal injury lawyer. There's a young staffer for New York governor Andrew Cuomo who's got the money and connections that come with that. He's driving a 1999 Ford Winnebago to every town in the district.
有一位既是社区活动家也是人身伤害律师的人。还有一位年轻的纽约州长安德鲁·库莫（Andrew Cuomo）的工作人员，他拥有随之而来的金钱和人脉。他正驾驶着一辆1999年的福特温尼巴格（Winnebago）房车前往选区的每个城镇。
I'm going to visit all 163 in this RV.
我将乘坐这辆房车访问所有163个城镇。
Somebody must have pointed out how much pollution those old RVs pump out, because now he tells audiences he's buying carbon offsets. And then there are three candidates who have raised the most money. Each has raised over a million dollars. There's Antonio Delgado, the lawyer from the lobbying firm, Brian Flynn, the medical devices executive, and an Iraq veteran named Pat Ryan.
一定有人指出那些旧房车排放了多少污染，因为现在他告诉听众他正在购买碳补偿。然后有三位筹款最多的候选人。每人都筹集了超过一百万美元。有安东尼奥·德尔加多（Antonio Delgado），那位游说公司的律师，布莱恩·弗林（Brian Flynn），医疗设备高管，以及一位名叫帕特·瑞安（Pat Ryan）的伊拉克战争老兵。
Beals has targeted these three. For him they represent the big money politics he's waging war against. Inconveniently for Beals, all three of these candidates sell themselves as progressives, identify themselves that way in opening remarks in ads. And I got to imagine, all seven candidates would be pretty dependable votes against the president.
比尔斯把这三个人定为目标。对他来说，他们代表了他正在与之开战的大金钱政治。对比尔斯来说不方便的是，这三位候选人都把自己标榜为进步派，在开场白和广告中这样定位自己。我想，所有七位候选人对比总统来说都是相当可靠的反对票。
They talk in samey ways about immigration. They all believe in climate change. They all support public education. But on the big dividing line issue for Democrats, the one that's supposed to separate the progressive team from the establishment team, Medicare for All, there's division.
他们以同样的方式谈论移民。他们都相信气候变化。他们都支持公共教育。但在民主党人的重大分界议题上，那个理应将进步派团队与建制派团队区分开来的议题——“全民医保”，存在分歧。
Of the three big money candidates, Flynn the medical devices CEO, he's for it. The other two, Ryan and Delgado, they are not for Medicare for All, which we know because there was a candidate forum in a town called Oneonta. They got to asked flat out, Medicare for All, are you for that? Yes or no. Here's their answers.
在那三位资金充足的候选人中，医疗设备CEO弗林是支持的。另外两位，瑞安和德尔加多，不支持“全民医保”，我们知道这一点是因为在一个叫奥尼昂塔（Oneonta）的城镇举行了一场候选人论坛。他们被直接问到，“全民医保”，你支持吗？是或否。这是他们的回答。
No.
不。
But Ryan and Delgado, they do this interesting thing you see in a lot of races around the country this year. While progressives are trying to draw this line in the sand, Ryan and Delgado are trying to blur the line out of existence. They're like, line? I don't see a line. Oh, look, Donald Trump! Get him!
但瑞安和德尔加多，他们做了这种今年在全国许多竞选中都能看到的有趣的事情。当进步派试图在沙滩上划出这条线时，瑞安和德尔加多试图把这条线模糊掉。他们就像，线？我没看见线。哦，看，唐纳德·特朗普！抓住他！
If you go to their websites or you watch their commercials, you might really think Ryan and Delgado agree with Beals on health care. Delgado's website, for instance, says, I will fight for universal affordable quality health care for everyone. He's running TV ads with that kind of language.
如果你浏览他们的网站或观看他们的广告，你可能真的会认为瑞安和德尔加多在医疗保健问题上同意比尔斯的观点。例如，德尔加多的网站说，我将为每个人争取普遍、负担得起、高质量的医疗保健。他正在播放带有这种语言的电视广告。
Let's go. That's awesome people. Love to get engaged and take this democracy back. We have to fight for universal, affordable, quality health care for everyone.
出发吧。那太棒了。很高兴能参与并夺回这个民主制度。我们必须为每个人争取普遍、负担得起、高质量的医疗保健。
I went to a fundraiser for Delgado at somebody's house. After he left, some people said they thought Delgado was for Medicare for All from the way that he talked but they weren't totally sure. They asked me, do you know? I said, well, I was just at this forum and he said no. Several felt misled. I told Delgado about it later.
我去参加了在某人家里为德尔加多举行的筹款活动。他离开后，一些人说他们从他谈话的方式中认为德尔加多支持“全民医保”，但他们并不完全确定。他们问我，你知道吗？我说，好吧，我刚才就在这个论坛上，他说不。几个人感到被误导了。我后来告诉了德尔加多这件事。
I would say, well, I'm sorry for the confusion first and foremost. What I've stated, and how I've stated my position has been abundantly clear. And then to the extent there were folks who were confused by that, I would certainly sit down with them and make sure they understood where I was coming from.
我会说，嗯，首先也是最重要的，我很抱歉引起了困惑。我已经陈述了，而且我陈述我立场的方式一直非常清晰。如果有人因此感到困惑，我肯定会坐下来和他们谈谈，确保他们了解我的立场。
Delgado's attitude is, let's just get everyone covered somehow. Saying, let's have government pay for everybody, Medicare for All, that narrows your options, alienates some voters, and it ignores specific realities.
德尔加多的态度是，让我们想办法覆盖所有人。说，“让政府为每个人买单”、“全民医保”，这会缩小你的选择范围，疏远一些选民，而且它忽视了具体的现实。
Oh, well, some of the specific realities include the fact that currently 153 million folks right now are relying on employer-based insurance. That's a lot of people. And a good number of those folks actually like their insurance. On top of that, we do not have an administrative apparatus yet developed across the nation that can meaningfully and responsibly and effectively transition to a completely government controlled system.
哦，嗯，一些具体的现实包括目前有1.53亿人正在依赖雇主提供的保险这一事实。那是很多人。而且这些人中的相当一部分人实际上喜欢他们的保险。最重要的是，我们目前还没有在全国范围内建立起一个可以有意义地、负责任地、有效地过渡到完全由政府控制系统的行政机构。
This can either seem like a totally reasonable and realistic way to think about the politics of health care in this country, or it can sound the way that it sounds to Beals and his supporters-- like a sellout, like Delgado doesn't stand with them at all. Here's Beals.
这要么看起来像是考虑这个国家医疗保健政治的完全合理和现实的方式，要么对比尔斯和他的支持者来说听起来像是出卖，像是德尔加多根本不站在他们这一边。这是比尔斯。
That's not a minor point of difference. That's a chasm. Everybody knows that's just a fig leaf for accepting corporate influence over the issue and refusing to take on a very powerful lobby and industry. That's all that that is.
那不是一个小分歧点。那是一个深渊。每个人都知道那只是接受企业对该议题影响力，并拒绝挑战一个非常强大的游说团体和行业的遮羞布。那只是那样而已。
Beals finds it galling that anyone could think he and Delgado want the same thing on health care. He's really frustrated by it. And he sees his role in this race to call this out, and to call it the role of money in the race, and to go after the mainstream big money candidates. In Beals' eyes, they embody everything that's wrong with the party. And there's plenty in their bios to set him off.
比尔斯觉得任何人会认为他和德尔加多在医疗保健上想要同样的东西简直是不可理喻。他对此感到非常沮丧。他认为自己在这次竞选中的角色就是揭露这一点，揭露金钱在竞选中的角色，并去对付那些主流的大金钱候选人。在比尔斯的眼里，他们体现了党内一切错误的东西。他们的履历中有足够多的东西能激怒他。
Last week he sent me this ad. Brian Flynn, the medical devices guy who financed his campaign with $700,000 of his own money, whose company manufactures overseas, he put out an ad where he says quote, "billionaires and corporations have rigged the system against us." In the ad there's a picture of Flynn. He's wearing a $9,000 watch, a Rolex. Like he didn't even know enough to take it off.
上周他发给我这个广告。布莱恩·弗林（Brian Flynn），那个用自己70万美元资金资助竞选、公司在海外制造产品的医疗设备男，他发布了一个广告，引用说：“亿万富翁和企业已经操纵了系统反对我们。”广告里有一张弗林的照片。他戴着一块9000美元的手表，劳力士。就像他甚至不知道该把它摘下来。
At every candidate forum I've seen, Beals has gone after those guys, accusing them of being bought and sold, tied to all the big donations they've taken.
在我见过的每一场候选人论坛上，比尔斯都去攻击那些人，指责他们被收买和出卖，与他们接受的所有大额捐赠捆绑在一起。
We have to stop these practices. We have to stop selling our seat. We have to stop selling our representation.
我们必须停止这些做法。我们必须停止出卖我们的席位。我们必须停止出卖我们的代表权。
Here he is in November, in a packed middle school auditorium.
这是他在11月，在一个挤满人的中学礼堂里。
--corporate power has bought out our own representative. And it has bought out our own ability to take control of our economy and have the jobs we need to have. Unfortunately, three of the candidates here are working for those large corporations. One of them shut down a factory in New York State, in Buffalo, moving jobs to the Dominican Republic. Another one of them works for one of the largest lobbying law firms in the United States and does white collar criminal defense for those companies when they--
——企业权力已经买断了我们自己的代表。它买断了我们控制经济的能力，并获得我们需要的工作。不幸的是，这里的三个候选人都在为那些大公司工作。其中一个在纽约州布法罗关闭了一家工厂，将工作岗位转移到了多米尼加共和国。另一个为美国最大的游说律师事务所之一工作，并在他们——时为这些公司做白领犯罪辩护。
I didn't realize that it was going to be shocking for anybody that I would say it. But you could feel it. I mean, I don't know if I believe in ESP. But I do believe that when a human being beside you is rising into rage there is some sort of black cloud emerging, and I felt it.
我没意识到我这么说会给任何人带来冲击。但你能感觉到。我的意思是，我不知道我是否相信ESP（超感官知觉）。但我确实相信，当身旁的人陷入愤怒时，会有一种黑云浮现，而我感觉到了。
You felt sort of like the room go cold?
你感觉像是房间变冷了？
I felt the candidate go cold.
我感觉候选人变冷了。
Beals says he was surprised by how strong the reaction was, onstage but then also afterwards.
比尔斯说，他对反应如此强烈感到惊讶，在台上是这样，后来也是。
Afterwards, one of the county chairs came up to my chief of staff and said, he can't do that. She said, no one likes Dem on Dem violence. And the county chair said the same thing to me personally-- stop this. No one likes Dem on Dem violence. And I said, I don't-- Dem on Dem violence? You know, that's a conversation. Nobody was hit.
后来，其中一位县主席走到我的参谋长面前说，他不能那样做。她说，没有人喜欢民主党打民主党。那位县主席也对我个人说了同样的话——停止这样。没有人喜欢民主党打民主党。我说，我没有——民主党打民主党？你知道，那是一场谈话。没有人被打。
His opponents respond with an argument you hear from lots of Democrats right now. This is Gareth Rhodes, the former gubernatorial staffer.
他的对手回应了一个你现在从许多民主党人那里听到的论点。这是加雷斯·罗兹（Gareth Rhodes），前州长幕僚。
The way we don't win is by attacking each other and bringing each other down. We need--
我们获胜的途径不是相互攻击、相互拉低。我们需要——
Here's Pat Ryan, veteran.
这是帕特·瑞安（Pat Ryan），老兵。
I got to say something after what was just said, all the Democrats in this room have to stand together, period. That is how we--
在刚才说的话之后，我必须说点什么，这个房间里的所有民主党人都必须团结一致，句号。这就是我们如何——
And I was told, don't do it. It gives ammunition for John Faso.
而且我被告知，不要这样做。这给约翰·法索提供了弹药。
That is, Beals attacks will make it easier for Faso to beat whoever wins the primary.
也就是说，比尔斯的攻击将使约翰·法索更容易击败无论谁赢得了初选。
Which is to me, ridiculous. The idea that it provides ammunition to Faso, give me a break. These people will invent all the ammunition they want and everything I'm talking about is there, is simply people's resumes. And I mean, what is a primary? A primary is about the party and about what the party stands for.
对我来说，这是荒谬的。它为法索提供了弹药的想法，给我歇会吧。这些人会编造他们想要的所有弹药，而我谈论的一切都在那里，简直就是人们的履历。我的意思是，什么是初选？初选是关于党以及党所代表的内容。
So if you were to show me, persuasively, another place where this conversation is going to happen, well then maybe you'll convince me. Oh, no, no, Jeff, we're doing that over there, on this day, with the DCCC at our platform conference. OK, maybe. I don't know. I can't imagine what the scenario would be. But if you're not going to show me a place where it's going to happen then it damn well better happen here.
所以如果你能说服我，还有另一个会发生这种谈话的地方，那么也许你会说服我。哦，不，不，杰夫，我们正在那边、在那天、在我们的纲领大会上和DCCC谈论那个。好吧，也许。我不知道。我无法想象那会是什么场景。但如果你不打算给我展示一个它会发生的地方，那么它最好在这里发生。
It's typical for the party, the DCCC, to check in with candidates and for campaigns to let them know how things are going. And every three months, the DCCC sends Beals fundraising goals-- $450,000, $500,000, what he's supposed to raise that quarter. The kind of money they believe is necessary to compete against a Republican in a district like this. Beals missed all those fundraising goals. He's raised about $316,000, which might have been respectable a decade ago, but these days is near the bottom rung of viability.
对于党、DCCC来说，与候选人核对情况以及竞选团队让他们知道事情进展如何是典型的做法。每三个月，DCCC都会给比尔斯发送筹款目标——45万美元、50万美元，他那个季度应该筹集多少钱。他们认为在像这样的选区与共和党人竞争所必需的资金。比尔斯错过了所有那些筹款目标。他筹集了大约31.6万美元，这在十年前可能还算体面，但这些天已接近生存能力的底层。
He thinks they don't get what he's doing or the kind of campaign he's trying to run. He says the fundraising goals aren't just this neutral practical bar to get over. They come with ideology.
他认为他们根本不明白他在做什么，或者他试图开展的那种竞选活动。他说筹款目标不仅仅是需要跨越的中性实际门槛。它们带有意识形态。
When the DCCC was saying, raise x dollars by this date, what they were really saying was, adopt these positions and call the following people who are well known, who will contribute to a campaign if you have those positions. And you'll have this much money by that date. There was an ideological message there but the fake of it was just asking for the money.
当DCCC说，在那个日期前筹集X美元时，他们真正说的是，采用这些立场并给以下众所周知的、如果你有这些立场就会为竞选捐款的人打电话。在那天之前，你就会有这么多钱。那里有一个意识形态的信息，但它的伪装仅仅是要求钱。
Party officials insist that the fundraising goals, they're not ideological. They're practical. It's reality. Ian Russell used to be the political director for the DCCC. He says a campaign like Beals is imagining can win, but it's a lot harder and would require a huge grassroots organization.
党内官员坚持认为筹款目标不是意识形态的。它们是实际的。那是现实。伊恩·罗素（Ian Russell）曾是DCCC的政治主任。他说，像比尔斯构想的那样的竞选活动是可以获胜的，但这要困难得多，而且需要一个庞大的草根组织。
And he says in a district like New York 19, because it's so spread out, a lot of the fight happens on TV. If you're not running ads in the general election you let your Republican opponent control the conversation. In Russell's experience, if a campaign like Beals' does make it through the primary, the party can end up in a tough spot. They've got a limited amount of money. They don't want to pull money away from other races so that they can prop up an underfunded campaign like Beals.
他说在像纽约第19选区这样的选区，因为它太分散了，很多斗争发生在电视上。如果你不在普选中播放广告，你就让你的共和党对手控制了谈话。根据罗素的经验，如果像比尔斯那样的竞选活动通过了初选，党最终可能会陷入困境。他们的资金有限。他们不想从其他竞选中抽走资金来支持像比尔斯这样资金不足的竞选活动。
The DCCC isn't the Salvation Army and shouldn't be the Salvation Army. Their job is to help democratic nominees who are viable get elected. They have to make tough calls about who to fund. Those calls are not made based on ideology. They're not made on anything except viability.
DCCC不是救世军，也不应该是救世军。他们的工作是帮助有实力的民主党提名人当选。他们必须就资助谁做出艰难的决定。这些决定不是基于意识形态。它们除了实力之外什么都不基于。
That's been the case. It's always the case. It's not without controversy. But it's an unfortunate symptom of our political system right now that candidates have to be able to raise the money to compete. The Republicans have tens of millions of dollars in dark money at their disposal.
一直都是这样。它总是这样。这并非没有争议。但这是我们政治系统目前的一个不幸症状，候选人必须有能力筹集到资金来竞争。共和党人拥有数千万美元的黑钱可供支配。
Democrats have to fight back. It's selfish and irresponsible if a nominee in a must win seat isn't pulling his or her weight and doing what they need to do to raise the money. If candidates aren't able to raise at least some of those resources on their own and show that they're willing to put in the work, it A, substantially decreases the chance they'll get elected in the first place. But B, it requires the DCCC to move money in from other districts. Or, even worse, can result in a district coming off the board because the Democratic candidate just gets buried.
民主党人必须反击。如果一个必赢席位的提名人没有尽到他或她的责任，也没有做他们需要做的事情来筹集资金，那是自私和不负责任的。如果候选人没有能力自己筹集至少部分资源并表现出他们愿意付出努力，那么A，这大大降低了他们当选的可能性。但B，它要求DCCC从其他选区转移资金。或者，更糟糕的是，可能导致该选区因为民主党候选人被埋没而退出竞争。
I put to him Beals case, that the donors the party steers him toward have a moderate agenda. And so what he says is, de facto, the fundraising goals you're giving for me are an ideological agenda.
我向他提出了比尔斯的观点，即党引导他接触的捐赠者有温和派纲领。所以他说，事实上，你们给我的筹款目标是一个意识形态的纲领。
That's a cop out. That's a cop out. That's just not the case. I'm sure there are many moderate donors who are writing checks. But there's also an excited progressive wing in the party that's helping candidates raise millions and millions of dollars. Again, in this district Zephyr Teachout's an example of that.
那是逃避。那是逃避。事实并非如此。我相信有很多温和派捐赠者在开支票。但党内也有一个兴奋的进步派，正在帮助候选人筹集数百万美元。再说一次，在这个选区，泽菲尔·蒂考特（Zephyr Teachout）就是一个例子。
Zephyr Teachout's a person. She's a progressive who ran against Faso in 2016. Russell points out that Teachout raised about $5 million with politics a lot like Beals. She did that by making herself a little famous with progressives. She did things like get on MSNBC so then she could get small donations from progressives all over the country. Russell says that's what candidates like Beals have to do.
泽菲尔·蒂考特是一个人。她是一位在2016年与法索竞选的进步派。罗素指出，蒂考特凭借与比尔斯非常相似的政治立场筹集了约500万美元。她通过让自己在进步派中变得有点出名来做到这一点。她做了诸如上MSNBC之类的事情，这样她就可以从全国各地的进步派那里获得小额捐款。罗素说，这就是像比尔斯这样的候选人必须做的事情。
I've worked for Howard Dean in 2003, 2004, who helped create this idea, invent this idea of asking people for money on the internet. You can give people the chance to come in and help your campaign if it's a cause that excites them and inspires them. But you have to put the work out to make it happen. You can't just sit back and expect somebody else to come and do the work for you, or for the DCCC to come in and bail you out. That's just not how it works.
我曾在2003年、2004年为霍华德·迪恩（Howard Dean）工作，他帮助创造了这个想法，发明了这个在互联网上向人们要钱的想法。如果这是一项能让他们兴奋并激励他们的事业，你可以给人们机会进来帮助你的竞选。但你必须付出努力才能实现它。你不能只是坐享其成，指望别人来为你做这项工作，或者指望DCCC进来为你买单。那根本不是这样运作的。
Beals relationship with the party went steadily downhill. And by February he says, it was nothing but arguments about him missing fundraising goals. And then came this phone call. Beals and two people from the campaign, with the DCCC's northeast political director.
比尔斯与党的关系稳步下滑。到了二月，他说，除了关于他错过筹款目标的争论之外，什么都没有。然后接到了这个电话。比尔斯和竞选团队的两个人，与DCCC的东北部政治主任。
You know, we get on the phone and the conversation turns to money instantly.
你知道，我们接通了电话，谈话立刻转向了金钱。
Then, according to Beals, someone on his end confronts the DCCC about this polling data that they'd given to two of the big money candidates, Brian and Delgado. They ask, could we get that too? The DCCC says, we can share that with you. But it doesn't get resolved before the conversation turns back to money.
然后，据比尔斯说，他那端的人就DCCC交给两个大金钱候选人布莱恩和德尔加多的民调数据与DCCC对质。他们问，我们也能得到那个吗？DCCC说，我们可以与你分享那个。但在谈话转向金钱之前，它并没有得到解决。
And they just say, you don't have enough money to run for Congress.
他们只是说，你没有足够的钱来竞选国会议员。
That's sort of flat out?
就那么直截了当？
Yeah. And I say, we're running a thriving campaign. There's tons of volunteers. People are rallying to the message. You know, I see every reason to believe that we're putting this together and we're building something real.
是的。我说，我们正在进行一场蓬勃发展的竞选。有无数的志愿者。人们正在向这个信息靠拢。你知道，我看到了相信我们正在把这一切拼凑起来并且我们正在建立一些真实东西的每一个理由。
We're going to keep running. And then he says to me, don't think if you win the primary people will help you. There will be lots of other choices out there. And--
我们将继续竞选。然后他对我说，如果你赢了初选，不要认为人们会帮助你。外面还会有很多其他的选择。而且——
Meaning what, like people will put money into different races? Or like--
意思是说，像人们会把钱投入到不同的竞选中？还是——
Yes. Yeah, exactly, as in people will just skip New York 19 if Jeff Beals is the nominee.
是的。是的，正是如此，就像人们如果杰夫·比尔斯成为提名人，他们就会跳过纽约第19选区一样。
A DCCC spokesperson wouldn't discuss the specifics of what happened on that call but told me the party would work with Beals if he became the nominee. At the same time, the former DCCC political director, Ian Russell, he told me if a candidate gets through the primary that the party doesn't think is strong, they will sometimes write off districts they think are a lost cause. Since that phone call, Beals says, his campaign has not spoken with the DCCC.
DCCC的一位发言人不会讨论那次电话的具体内容，但告诉我说，如果比尔斯成为提名人，党会与他合作。与此同时，前DCCC政治主任伊恩·罗素（Ian Russell）告诉我，如果候选人通过了初选但党认为他不强，他们有时会注销他们认为是败局的选区。自那次电话以来，比尔斯说，他的竞选团队没有与DCCC交谈过。
Democrats are so desperate to win this year. I heard it over and over. And though Beals has this theory on why a campaign like his can beat a Republican in the fall, even some progressives are nervous to go along with him.
民主党人今年非常渴望获胜。我反复听到这个。尽管比尔斯对比尔斯式的竞选活动为何能在秋季击败共和党人有自己的理论，但即使是一些进步派也对跟随他感到紧张。
One progressive group got into a particularly bitter fight over all this. The group's Citizen Action. It's a branch of a national group. There's lots of chapters. Very active chapter in New York. Their volunteers run Faso Fridays.
一个进步派团体在这一切上陷入了特别激烈的斗争。该团体是“公民行动”（Citizen Action）。这是一个全国性团体的分支。有很多分会。在纽约有非常活跃的分会。他们的志愿者运行“法索星期五”。
Oriana Mayorga was in charge of Citizen Action's endorsement committee in New York 19. She moved to the district to work for Citizen Action as an organizer. She's a Beals supporter. In January, Mayorga gathered in an endorsement committee of 12 who interviewed the candidates. They discussed, then they voted.
奥里亚娜·马约加（Oriana Mayorga）负责“公民行动”在纽约第19选区的背书委员会。她搬到选区为“公民行动”担任组织者。她是比尔斯的支持者。一月，马约加聚集了一个由12人组成的背书委员会，面试了候选人。他们讨论，然后他们投票。
There were seven votes for Jeff Beals and five for Antonio Delgado. People wanted Jeff Beals. That was--
有七票投给杰夫·比尔斯，五票投给安东尼奥·德尔加多。人们想要杰夫·比尔斯。那是——
Not a huge shocker. Citizen Action is progressive. They hold events and rallies for single payer health care.
不是什么巨大的震动。公民行动是进步派的。他们为“全民医保”举办活动和集会。
We're like, Citizen Action is this grassroots organization that fights corporate power. So in no way would I think that they would want to endorse somebody who is from Wall Street, has all these corporate donors backing them and isn't for Medicare for All.
我们当时想，公民行动是一个打击企业权力的草根组织。所以无论如何我都不认为他们会想背书一个来自华尔街、有所有这些企业捐赠者支持而且不支持“全民医保”的人。
Mayorga sent word to the state leadership of Citizen Action, here was our vote. But what happened next surprised her. State leaders said the vote had been too close, closer than they wanted. Essentially, look at this some more and try again. Mayorga says following that first vote, state leaders called members of the committee. They told people they thought Delgado was the stronger candidate.
马约加把消息传给了“公民行动”的州领导层，这就是我们的投票。但接下来的事情让她感到惊讶。州领导层说投票太接近了，比他们想要的更接近。本质上，再看一看这个，再试一次。马约加说在那次第一次投票之后，州领导层打电话给了委员会成员。他们告诉人们，他们认为德尔加多是更强有力的候选人。
The deputy director spoke very frankly. I mean, it was not-- it wasn't really behind the scenes. She spoke frankly about it with me and while there were volunteers in the office, saying that the organization really felt that Delgado was the most viable candidate. He had the money and he had the support, but that he would have to be for Medicare for All for us to get behind him.
副主任说得非常坦率。我的意思是，那不是——那真的不是幕后的。她在办公室里有志愿者时跟我坦率地说，组织确实感到德尔加多是最有实力的候选人。他有钱，也有支持，但他必须支持“全民医保”我们才能支持他。
They brought Delgado in and they told them that. But he refused to back Medicare for All. What followed was a series of tough meetings, circular arguments, turning over the coin of idealism and pragmatism. The same tortured question from the Sanders versus Clinton race.
他们把德尔加多带进来，告诉了他这些。但他拒绝支持“全民医保”。随之而来的是一系列艰难的会议、循环论证、翻转理想主义和实用主义的硬币。与桑德斯对克林顿竞选中的同一个痛苦议题。
This time around though it was, should we back Beals? He's more progressive. He's like us. Others were like, Delgado has more money. We worry Beals can't compete.
这一次虽然是，我们应该支持比尔斯吗？他更进步。他像我们。其他人说，德尔加多有更多的钱。我们担心比尔斯无法竞争。
Mayorga says the whole thing was kind of awful. At one point, someone ran out of the room with a nosebleed. But eventually another vote was taken-- seven for Delgado, five for Beals. People in charge were like, OK, if that's our endorsement can you Beals folks live with that?
马约加说这一切都有点糟糕。有一次，有人鼻血流出来跑出房间。但最终进行了另一次投票——7票投给德尔加多，5票投给比尔斯。负责人说，好的，如果这是我们的背书，你们比尔斯的人能接受吗？
And the Beals supporters were in an uproar, right?
而比尔斯的支持者群情激愤，对吧？
They were like, we voted with the same split for Beals and were told it was too close.
他们就像，我们以同样的票数投给了比尔斯，却被告知太接近了。
The numbers were now 7-5. We were in the same place, just a different candidate. So technically speaking, both times one would assume that means that it's too close.
数字现在是7-5。我们处于同一个地方，只是不同的候选人。所以从技术上讲，两次人们都会假设这意味着太接近了。
A few things happened after that meeting. There was another meeting. A bunch of Beals supporters couldn't be there, and one last Beals supporter caved. Then Mayorga told her bosses she was upset about how this whole thing went. The following week she was fired.
那次会议后发生了一些事。又开了一次会。一群比尔斯的支持者无法到场，最后一个比尔斯支持者屈服了。然后马约加告诉她的老板，她对比这一切的发生感到不满。接下来的一周她被解雇了。
After a careful and deliberative process of our local endorsement committee and our--
经过我们当地背书委员会和我们的——仔细和深思熟虑的过程
In May, Citizen Action officially endorsed Antonio Delgado.
五月，“公民行动”正式背书了安东尼奥·德尔加多。
That candidate is Antonio Delgado.
那个候选人是安东尼奥·德尔加多。
Delgado tweeted out the endorsement calling it quote, "the progressive stamp of approval."
德尔加多发推文感谢背书，称其为引用：“进步派的认可印章”。
It's like not even-- I mean, it's kind of funny. I mean, Antonio Delgado is Hillary Clinton. I mean, like, that's just the truth. Like he is the Hillary Clinton of the race and Jeff Beals is the Bernie Sanders.
这甚至不是——我的意思是，这有点好笑。我的意思是，安东尼奥·德尔加多就是希拉里·克林顿。我的意思是，那是事实。就像他是竞选中的希拉里·克林顿，而杰夫·比尔斯是伯尼·桑德斯。
When I talk to the DCCC and progressives, one of the things they all said was that they were worried about how Democrats were going to handle the whole influx of enthusiasm this year. Essentially, if Democrats didn't handle the situation right people could get alienated. The opportunity could get squandered. I couldn't help but think of that when I was talking to Mayorga.
当我与DCCC和进步派交谈时，他们都说的一件事是，他们担心民主党人将如何处理今年所有的热情涌入。本质上，如果民主党人不正确处理这种情况，人们可能会被疏远。机会可能会被挥霍。当我和马约加交谈时，我不禁想到了这一点。
To be fair, after this November I'm no longer a Democrat. I'm 100% a Working Families Party person. So this will be my last Democratic primary I'll be voting in.
公平地说，今年11月之后，我不再是民主党人了。我100%是“劳动家庭党”（Working Families Party）的人。所以这将是我参加的最后一次民主党初选。
Oh, wow, you feel-- you're just like, I'm done.
哦，哇，你感觉——你就像是，我受够了。
Oh, I'm done. Yeah, I'm done. I really am. I think that we have to make the decision. Do we want to support progressive candidates? Or do we want to go with the safe bets, you know, these Hillary Clintons, these Antonio Delgado candidates?
哦，我受够了。是的，我受够了。我真的受够了。我认为我们必须做出决定。我们是想支持进步派候选人？还是我们想选择那些安全的选择，你知道，这些希拉里·克林顿，这些安东尼奥·德尔加多候选人？
Hi, how are you doing? I'm Jeff Beals. I saw beware of dog kisses, but--
嗨，你好吗？我是杰夫·比尔斯。我看到“小心狗吻”，但——
Yeah.
是的。
Those are kisses.
那是吻。
He's a good dog. He gets very excited when--
他是一只好狗。他会非常兴奋当——
Recently I follow Beals as he canvassed in Oneonta, a beautiful town up in the mountains of New York.
最近我追踪比尔斯，他在奥尼昂塔进行拉票，那是纽约山上一个美丽的城镇。
I'm running for Congress.
我正在竞选国会议员。
He moved quickly from one port to another with a keen eye out for Bernie Sanders stickers on bumpers and in windows.
他迅速地从一个地方移动到另一个地方，敏锐地关注着保险杠和窗户上的伯尼·桑德斯贴纸。
That's a telltale sign.
那是明显的迹象。
Though Beals says his relationship with the national party went cold, progressive groups have jumped in to help him. A group of former Sanders staffers, the Justice Democrats, and a group of former Sanders activists, the People for Bernie Sanders, they both endorse Beals. And those endorsements, they serve as this kind of shorthand for progressive voters. At one house this sweet guy named Dana came to the door. He had a Sanders sticker outside.
虽然比尔斯说他与全国党的关系变冷了，但进步派团体已经介入帮助他。一群前桑德斯工作人员，即“正义民主党人”（Justice Democrats），以及一群前桑德斯活动家，“伯尼·桑德斯人民”（People for Bernie Sanders），他们都背书了比尔斯。而这些背书，它们成为进步派选民的一种速记法。在一个房子里，这个叫达纳（Dana）的可爱家伙来到门口。他在外面贴了一张桑德斯贴纸。
I'm a Democrat, I'm a progressive.
我是民主党人，我是进步派。
OK, well me too. Me too. I've been-- I've been looking for you.
好的，我也是。我也是。我一直在——我一直在找你。
Beals gave his pitch. He's a teacher, thinks the economy is working against most people, Medicare for All-- then he mentioned the Justice Democrats, the endorsement by the former Sanders staffers.
比尔斯给出了他的推销词。他是一名教师，认为经济对大多数人不利，“全民医保”——然后他提到了正义民主党人，前桑德斯工作人员的背书。
If you're a Justice Democrat then you've already got my vote.
如果你是正义民主党人，那么你已经得到了我的投票。
Well, that's who I am. That's who I am.
好吧，那就是我。那就是我。
You don't need to spend a lot of time here. You can move on.
你不需要在这里花很多时间。你可以继续前进了。
This happened a number of times that day. As for the army of volunteers Beals knew he would need to win this kind of campaign, did he enlist them? Beals wouldn't say how many he has. But he did say they've knocked on over 40,000 doors. That's the same number Pat Ryan, the veteran, says his campaign has done. Antonio Delgado's campaign says they've knocked on 50,000. So at least by one measure he's keeping up, though Ryan and Delgado are both running TV ads and Beals is not. So far nobody has released an objective poll on the race. With seven candidates, the vote could split in some really weird ways. Everybody agrees someone could win without getting all that much of the vote.
那天这种情况发生了很多次。至于比尔斯知道他需要赢得这种竞选活动的志愿者大军，他招募到了吗？比尔斯没有说他有多少。但他确实说他们已经敲了超过4万扇门。这和老兵帕特·瑞安说他的竞选团队所做的数字一样。安东尼奥·德尔加多的竞选团队说他们敲了5万扇门。所以至少在一个衡量标准上，他保持着进度，尽管瑞安和德尔加多都在播放电视广告，而比尔斯没有。到目前为止，没有人发布过关于这次竞选的客观民调。七个候选人，选票可能会以一些非常奇怪的方式分裂。每个人都同意有人可能在没有获得那么多选票的情况下获胜。
Are you registered Democrats? Are any of you registered Democrats? Who's a registered Democrat?
你们是注册民主党人吗？你们中有人是注册民主党人吗？谁是注册民主党人？
One of the things that probably will happen, even if Beals doesn't win, some candidates like him probably will. Meaning if Democrats get a majority in the House, all these disagreements about who they are and what they should be are not going to go away. Their majority will be riddled with people who feel like the party is doing things wrong and who have spent the past year like Beals has, finding each other. That's what Beals is left to do these days. Now that school's out he starts canvassing around 8:00 AM. He keeps going until 9:00 at night. And every day, he tells me, he finds more people who feel the way that he does.
即使比尔斯没有赢，像他这样的候选人很可能会赢，这很可能会发生。意思是如果民主党在众议院获得多数，所有关于他们是谁以及他们应该是什么的这些分歧都不会消失。他们的多数席位将充斥着感觉党在做错事的人，以及像比尔斯一样花了一年时间寻找彼此的人。这就是比尔斯这些天剩下的工作。现在学校放假了，他从早上8点左右开始拉票。他一直持续到晚上9点。每一天，他告诉我，他都会发现更多像他那样感觉的人。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers on our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace. The people who put together our show today includes Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Catherine Maymondo, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们今天的节目由佐伊·切斯（Zoe Chace）制作。今天制作我们节目的人员包括本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、查纳·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）、凯瑟琳·梅蒙多（Catherine Maymondo）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
Special thanks today to Jeremy McCarter, Lucy Flores, Dustin Reidy, Tim Mynett, and Jonathan Smucker. Our website, Thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. We also have a slide show this week of Jeff Beals out talking to voters. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢杰里米·麦卡特（Jeremy McCarter）、露西·弗洛雷斯（Lucy Flores）、达斯汀·雷迪（Dustin Reidy）、蒂姆·迈内特（Tim Mynett）和乔纳森·斯穆克（Jonathan Smucker）。我们的网站Thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。我们本周还有杰夫·比尔斯外出与选民交谈的幻灯片。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换）提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I was driving him home this week and he pointed out this opening in the woods near his house I had never seen before, looked pretty creepy. He explained--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，我这周开车送他回家，他指出了他家附近树林里的一个我从未见过的开口，看起来相当阴森。他解释说——
That way lieth of the Goldman Sachs speech. That way lieth the Goldman Sachs speech. Don't. Don't.
那是高盛演讲的方向。那是高盛演讲的方向。别那样做。别。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。